knight takes pawn i i don't know maybe
okay interesting so hopefully it doesn't
work but i'm not sure it quite works
white would love to sacrifice a piece to
break open the structure
a huge blunder from manish giri that one
wasn't a mouse slip that was just a
blunder he gave up a piece and resigned
immediately oh what a strange moment
he just jumps up from his chair and he's
carrying losing this match
and there are they are discussing what
do you think they're talking about
talking about the game but but it's a
crazy moment at the end i mean i i don't
understand it
and you know the players are discussing
the game and you can see a niche one of
those he's upset walking off it could be
one of those oversights where you just
forget the rook is not defending that
square why is this uh a moment of
blindness yeah yeah
no i think it's one i don't know it's
just so weird i'm thinking it might be
one of those ones where you you click on
pieces
and you don't quite realize that you've
got things highlighted it could be a
double mouth slip as well very positive